pour revenir sur la démission du
gouvernement libanais françois el bacha
économiste et fondateur de l'ipda news
est avec nous françois el bacha merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
après la crise économique et de
gouvernance est désormais une crise
politique qui s'ajoute au contraire le
début d'un renouveau
bonsoir tout d'abord est ce que est ce
que la démission du gouvernement diable
n'est pas une manière de temporiser en
fait pour la classe politique que tout
le monde dénonce on s'attendait plutôt
justement à des élections législatives y
avait une demande d'ailleurs pour les
élections législatives anticipées selon
le processus constitutionnel
cette demande aurait dû être formulée
par le président de la république et
ensuite avait enfin proposé par le
gouvernement
c'est à dire que c'était le gouvernement
qui devait le faire cette question
serait de savoir donc quel sera le
prochain premier ministre
et a priori on va revenir sur des
négociations entre partis politiques
désigner le prochain premier ministre
et ça risque encore de tarder et le tard
d&o tardez donc pour le moment
l'hypothèse la plus probable c'est celle
d'une temporisation de la classe
politique et le temps nous manque
aujourd'hui économiquement et du point
de vue humain tout simplement des suites
de l'explosion
il y a un nom qui pourrait se dégager
concernant ce futur premier ministre ont
parlé et ont évoqué le retour de saad
hariri l'ancien premier ministre ou
d'une personne qui lui seraient affiliés
donc probablement ça cela sera rejeté
par la rue à l'heure actuelle mais voilà
où est ce qu'on en ait ce soir alors il
ya quelques minutes un par la voix de
son ministre des affaires étrangères la
france a appelé à la formation rapide
d'un gouvernement qui fasse ses preuves
un gouvernement qui fait ses preuves et
cela passe par quoi au fond pour le
moment il faut établir la confiance de
la population et la confiance de la
population doit passer par des élections
législatives anticipées
ce que craignent des partis politiques
et on a bien vu que la communauté
internationale
aujourd'hui à menacer de source
diplomatique française a menacé certains
dirigeants de sanctions
il va y avoir la visite prochaine de là
haut fonctionnaire américain le
sous-secrétaire d'état en charge du
proche orient je crois et des choses
comme ça donc il ya une mobilisation de
la communauté internationale
la question c'est que ce serait plutôt
de savoir si la classe politique
libanaise va résister à ces pressions
internationales ou non jusqu'à présent
elle a très bien résisté elle était
capable
plutôt de le continuer à avoir des
problèmes en interne et de ne pas
répondre à cette question internationale
et ne pas répondre en interne aux
demandes de la population étaient de
résister jusqu'au bout jusqu'au pire et
finalement cette démission du
gouvernement
c'est pas liée à la pression de la
communauté internationale justement il y
avait déjà avant l'explosion du port de
beyrouth une grande pression interne de
la part de certains partis on avait plus
en fait un de vos z11 de vous inviter il
ya quelques semaines par les deux
parties des banques
une manière très simple on avait même
dans l'opposition ou dans la majorité
des gens qui ont requis représentait une
sorte de mafia économique et ces
personnes-là souhaité faire tomber le
gouvernement
maintenant l'explosion entre guillemets
constitue pour eux un momentum une
opportunité pour ces retombées le
gouvernement donc il faut absolument
aussi que la population comprenne les
enjeux qui sont derrière tout ça et il
faut agir de manière intelligente fixé
un objectif qui est celle d'organiser
des élections législatives anticipées le
plus rapidement possible et arriver à
cet objectif
quels que soient les moyens utilisés
alors une nouvelle opposition à un
composé d'une grande alliance de
différents partis citoyens souhaitent se
mettre en place
c'est d'ailleurs à ce que réclame la
contestation qu'est ce que l'on peut en
attendre selon vous pour le moment la
société civile n'a pas réussi à
s'organiser et on aurait dû le voir
depuis octobre
pour le moment donc
pas par des deux coalitions de partis
c'est très hétéroclite en fin de compte
ya des mots d'ordre par ci par là le
problème c'est un problème
organisationnel
on a on peut pas encore parler de partis
d'opposition de la société civile en
tant que tel alors lévy bayen alesi je
vous en prie et et leur demain entre
guillemets sont différentes
ils n'ont pas de plan d'action réelle
pour justement mettre en place une
dynamique de changement ils veulent le
changement mais pour cela ils doivent
formuler un plan et ce plan manquent
aujourd'hui ils ont intérêt et le
message qu'il faut passer c'est qu'ils
ont intérêt à s'organiser sur le terrain
et sur une nouvelle chaussure au niveau
organisationnel
alors pour conclure est ce qu'il y
aurait une figure un groupe finalement
capable de répondre aux attentes des
libanais aujourd'hui pour le moment
c'est plutôt le chaos tout simplement la
classe politique elle-même s'est
totalement il ya plus de confiance
le pays est un pays secteur il faut
transcender
déjà ce côté sectaire et confessionnels
de figures politiques à l'heure actuelle
il n'y en a pas vraiment et l'opposition
entre guillemets aussi au système
traditionnel est trop hétéroclite eto'o
est éclatée et ainsi de suite c'est pour
cela qu'il ya un gros risque de chaos
et c'est ce chaos qu'il faut éviter
surtout que le liban n'a plus le temps
d'attendre aujourd'hui n'a plus le luxe
du temps normalement
merci beaucoup françois elle vachal
avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue